つじゃなきゃゲじゃリーガーじゃーんグランが焼きそばのヴァンガード
続行とセレクトは
恋
なんか印刷が
雑貨をが縦長になっています
きますよ明日らしいペヤングですフェアも爽快したら絶対に叩かれるんですよ
なんでもうねぇを叩かれていくからね恋野恋野恋はアハズは知らないんですけど中に
あのヴァンガードのカードは
一番入ってるっていうことだよそしてここでしか手に入らないという
も多分ヴァンガーダーにとってはもう最高の約妻ですね
戦コレや枚数を出してカード入ってるって事はまつがえてカード食べさせてを入れない
ですか
あっはい
うわぁデーター変なカードでました
残雪やって叩かれるんかなここが俺は分からないんですよね
団などって何なんですか
面白いんですかね
僕が強いに病だった時は今なんですけど
遊戯王とデュエルマスターズが流行ってました
ん
今はヴァンガードって言うんですね
あっはぁ
いやこれはいたって普通の焼きそばの匂いですねこれただの日なんかじゃないんですか
ん
いただきます
こんな感じです
頭痛熱場所か
おいず
その提案後約蕎麦は美味しいんですよ本来ああ
入り味出てます
ジャケットぜひ
あのヴァンガード欲しい c
焼きそばも食べたいみたいなそういうなんか欲望の塊みたいな人
ぜひ買ってみてくださいじゃ
ん